the first time i took
ecstasy was in manchester
thinking what is this this is pretty
boring and all of a sudden my knees just
completely buckled
and time just started to stand still
the whole room is just throbbing and
everybody's dancing and the music just
pulsing into my head all these beeps and
weird noises like signals from outer
space that i didn't understand
are now completely making sense
i never wanted the party to end after
that night raving became my religion
i'm shaun atwood known as one of the
biggest exes traffickers
in the u.s rave scene my local nickname
was english sean
i was up against one of the kosa nostras
most notorious killers
as a young person i set a goal to be a
millionaire
by age 30. greed is good was my mantra
i flew out to arizona because
it had dazzled me as a teenager
[Music]
the plane comes in and you're looking
out the window
and you're seeing all these swimming
pools in people's backyards
the sun's always shining it's almost 50
degrees in the summer
and as soon as they hear the english
accent they roll out the red carpet
but the rave scene was barely starting
they didn't even know where ecstasy was
so there was this huge
gap in the market
[Music]
when i threw my first rave locking down
all the ravers just going off with the
strobe lights pulsing
i knew that this was my calling in life
as an experiment i decided to order a
thousand pills out of la
[Music]
all this stuff goes in one weekend i've
made thousands
of dollars just like that parting my ass
off
and that was when i decided to go full
time trafficking
[Music]
you